All right. Let's take a look at the code
here. So first we create a pandas data frame
called hr_year, that reads in the hr_year.csv file. Then
we just print ggplot where we say that our
data source is going to be the hr_year data
frame. And the variables that we want to plot are
year ID and home runs. Then we add geom
points, with the color red. Then we add geom
lines to the color red and then let's add some
labels so our plot is able to interpret. So we'll title
it total home runs by year. With the x label year
and the y label home runs. We just print this and
we'll generate our chart. Now let's see what this produces.
Here's the plot that this generates. We see that we have
a bunch of points that are red, where we indicate the
number of home runs hit every year. They're connected by red
lines, which gives us some sense of the rate of
change. We have years on the X axis. Home runs on
the Y axis. We have the labels that we put in.
And also the title that we told our plot to show.